[Music]
there hasn't been a route to in new
jersey since 1942.
it's all wonderful repeating your
misdirection from the previous episode
hoping it will stick
slow-going one of the most orgasmic
moments in mcu history
splorgasming parts of this episode
especially those stairs and the opening
credits running through the park have
super duper full house vibes which is
honestly a dick move by elizabeth here
it wasn't enough she had to usurp her
twin sister's fame she has to own the
only thing they had left
if you go to sleep i promise you will be
my favorite
twin sibling favoritism whether joking
or not this can really [ __ ] up a kid's
identity
i mean probably not more than skipping
entire developmental stages but still
keep it down leslie's about to get my
leg over getting my leg over
also horny viz continues to be horny and
look we're totally sex positive around
here but i'm also 100
sex positive you should probably put the
infants down first
look i think it's working expecting a
baby to suck on a binky coated in
synthetic ear wax
agnes i was just fluffing this pillow
with my
face seriously viz enough with the
sexual euphemisms
do you want me to take that again
breaking character you're better than
that catherine
honestly i can't believe they left that
in fussy babies meet
buns of steel we dare you to stay away
for the life of me i can't think of a
way her buns of steel will play into
quieting these babies that isn't making
me extremely uncomfortable
lavender supposed to have a calming
effect spraying anything onto an infant
without researching first to be sure
that the
supposed to is an absolutely will
looking at the fruit bowls here i'm
reminded of how often fruit goes bad in
my house and before you head to the
comments to complain about that not
being a sin on this show it absolutely
is
look at all those apples vision and wand
are the only apple eating [ __ ] in
this house
anything over five is just over fruiting
the more you look at this picture the
more it seems like your head was
photoshopped onto the wrong part of
someone else's body once you see it you
can't unsee it
i mean it's probably a real picture but
weren't there better pictures to choose
[Music]
[Laughter]
baby vision i'm only human guys but also
this
is giving me serious enemy mind vibes
and i'm not okay with that
oh sure tommy's name has nothing but
billy's name gets the exclamation point
this is clearly more favoritism and
ultimately just creates poor family ties
this random tiger on the table combined
with agnes bragging there's no taming
this
tiger is two bengal references in less
than 10 minutes and this is exactly the
kind of show that makes me spend 20
minutes thinking about what it means
and that's 20 minutes i could have been
mining bitcoin damn it
there's a briefing in 10 pants are
encouraged but not
mandatory what sort of operation is this
people can just free ball or go clam
mando willy milly
i need another blood draw no no no we're
done here
and because we aren't supposed to know
about monica's abnormalities yet this
works
translucent privacy curtains that needs
to be opaque so you can't opeq
it's an oversimplification of events but
yes
what in a tv show
you don't say monica should blast you
halfway across new jersey hyperbole
bring up the visual this entire
conversation has been the typical mcu
convenient self-advancing powerpoint
presentation
but suddenly somebody needs to be
instructed to pull something up and they
have it ready with a few clicks
why wasn't that in the original file
also it's a good thing that this console
self-orients so that wherever the camera
is we aren't looking at it upside down
but that's in direct violation of
section 36b of the sokovia accords
[Music]
just imagine being this guy in the
background your only job as an extra is
to stare at the back of deputy derpy's
head and look like you're desperately
trying to hold in a fart
all right that's it for now wow what a
waste of a debrief
this reminds me of attending staff
meetings where 98 of what is being
covered doesn't concern you at all
great you informed everyone who wand is
why she's dangerous and that she stole a
carcass i mean the carcass part is new
but is it all so exciting that literally
everyone had to stop their important
work to listen you know
i don't miss the crying but geez louise
did you have to learn to walk
you two never stay put but there are kid
crafts on the fridge so clearly they can
sit still long enough to make all this
um art oh look the lobster penis is back
and now it has more friends
this fish looks like another penis and
i'm not even sure what this is but
dragon maybe anyhow it's clear this room
goes by the 1980s too
duck abstract art and a heart standard
of interior design my kitchen window
told me someone got a new pooch
windows can't talk that a hunch someone
might pop over
with exactly the item we require
this talking toaster would be excellent
at tv sins
vision gets on to wanda for being
careless with her powers but earlier we
saw him dressed for family portrait day
at sears
as a turkey the easter bunny and santa
while still looking very much android
rambo is trying to figure out how to get
back into westview via some complex
thingamajig and honestly i'm not sure
why she's concerned
clearly suarez has many amazing things
at their disposal they can pop up a
sweet tent city at a moment's notice and
their standard issue uniforms include
neat little thumb cutouts
if you can do thumb cutouts what can't
you do this wall has turned from useful
way to track information on who's in
town to
why is there a whole row of wand and
vision at the top when they're already
in the center
someone's patting their serial killer
board she could have taken out thanos on
her own if he hadn't initiated a blitz i
mean
nobody else came close well i'd argue
that captain marvel came close
read it what are we looking for that
you're looking for the thing that just
happens to be set up on display in this
room right where you need it for
storytelling purposes
cool checks out are we being mind
controlled to see that right now
i mean she was wearing them when she
exited so this is a question you may
have wanted to ask when rambo was found
in the field
not naked can i borrow this whoa whoa
whoa whoa
this is a beyond reprehensible act by a
character we're supposed to love
it needlessly puts equipment and even
lives at risk for a display that has
already been confirmed by a test anyway
this is both reckless and pointless and
the only sane resolution to this choice
involves monica and handcuffs and
immediately removed from the case and
the agency
also no one hears the shots that are
fired despite this being a bustling base
nobody comes running to see what
shenanigans are afoot despite being on
high alert
honestly this scene may be the most
unbelievable part of this entire series
so you're telling me this is a
typewriter a rolodex and a calendar all
in one
don't forget that it's also a place to
discover copious amounts of pornographic
images and considering vision's apparent
sexual insatiability in this series you
know that's the first place he would go
what else can it do find me a wife
eventually yes so vision knows the
future
and if so how does he not know he's dead
i mean mostly dead or
temporarily dead but in no way dead
forever and ever
you have to stop her stop who she's in
my head
look marvel we can spot pronoun gaming a
mile away and our city senses are
all over this use of her and she so take
your sin for pronoun gaming and for
teasing us with this wanda or agnes
conundrum when we might have to wait
weeks for the answer
also this guy is briefly outside the
puppet masters control and my question
is
does that mean he can see he's talking
to a walking android corpse
something's scaring him assuming you can
understand a dog whimper
stay here disobedience
we can't see the drone on the broadcast
wand is framing it out of the shot
since when are the broadcasts you're
watching happening in concurrent real
time
disregard take the shot take the shot
with the missile that you have attached
to a drone built in the 80s
was the missile from the 80s too and if
so what sort of magical mumbo jumbo had
to happen for suar to find a drone from
the 80s just lying around in a nearby
new jersey warehouse
wait is it night outside the dome but
day inside we see earlier that it's
clearly bright out but out here it's
pitch black i get that wanda or whoever
could do this but we've seen it be night
on the show before and later it's
clearly night in the town behind her
the missile was just a precaution this
guy is it just me or these shots
targeting her cleavage a bit more than
her heart
geez even the laser sights are a bit
male gazy lagos
for when you make a mess you didn't mean
to that slogan second only to lagos
so strong even overly metaphorical blood
stains don't even stand a chance
don't worry he's sure to turn up your
mom won't let him get far
ma'am an important unknown character has
an unnecessary speaking line to set up
their existence for later cliche
by the way you can use this casual
superfluous introduction theory to spot
the killer in almost every single one of
the over 1000 various csi episodes
what i'm saying is watch out for the
mailman he's obviously the killer don't
age yourselves up
why would this be a response from the
kids what would growing up do to fix the
dead dog
you can't control me the way you do them
can't i the way wanda in this show uses
this
role credits moment to play into both
the story and themes of denial and grief
that are prevalent throughout this whole
episode
is such brilliant work that i have to
give another sin off keep it up marvel
and the mtu may rival the mcu
i wonder who is this asks the man who
despite being adamant about it the
entire episode is suddenly completely
unconcerned about revealing his identity
to strangers
[Applause]
what
i'm sorry about that thing with the
tesseract i just couldn't help myself
i know i'm a trickster mommy
come and play with us danny
[Music]
cowabunga dude dad i've never said
cowabunga in my life
your script sucks what happened to him
found him in my azalea bushes don't know
how many leaves he ate i didn't find him
until it was too late
siri how do you perform cpr
on a dog